I have a question who do you think are
the biggest vowel white racist the media
you think the media is racist
what please next question please don't
ask me any [ __ ] questions
okay let me go to the the next we're not
possible that I said I'll Focus let me
explain one are you happy that I said I
know I heard oh brother why are you
talking over yeah let me let me respond
yay Chris I'm Chris let's respond let me
respond right if you want me to go on if
I say to specify the business people
that have raped my people that just so
happened to be Jewish
I think what by doing what you've just
done I find that I'm not even Jewish and
I find that offensive why do you keep
having to do that I don't think you get
it at all I know you understand the
offense I actually am
uh a person that's classified as black
you know I classify myself as Jew uh
let's go top 10 in each one of these
categories right let's read Michael B
Jordan why would any of those okay why
would any of that hey bro hey hey bro I
ain't finished I ain't finished my
sentence
hey boy don't finish I told you
oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm
gonna finish my sentence or my idea
nothing you're saying has got anything
to do with the Tweet cool
so I was in the middle of a sentence boy
okay so are you going to allow me to
finish my sentence yes
you're you know a billionaire you can do
whatever the hell you want I'm just I'm
just saying to you that I don't think
you quite understand when you uh when
you talk about uh okay can I finish it's
not uh multi multi you're a
multi-billionaire okay well
congratulations but that doesn't change
the fact that when you insult the Jewish
people and say you're going Jessica on
three yo I want to prove first of all I
am Jew also the 12 lost tribes of Hebrew
do the math
do your research on it okay I had this
thing I had this like you know of course
I'm uh I'm a divorce and this is like a
a funny thing I thought being that her
name is no longer West
and my name is no longer yay if there
was ever I mean sorry being that her
name is no longer West and my name is
now only yay if we were ever to be
together again what would our name be
kimye
like say watch Elon Musk every product
the reason why Elon Musk is like a Steve
Jobs is
if he makes a flamethrower he would use
that flamethrower if he makes a cyber
truck he would use that cyber truck me
if I make some 3D printed boots you know
I'm gonna have the the 3D printed boots
on Wow every day
absolutely sir
here's the obvious go-to Biden doesn't
listen to Elon Musk
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come come get me
that's [ __ ]
when you watch that video of George
Floyd no it's not a butt it's not it's
notified
I know I know what you said wait I'm
gonna finish
I know what it means
be quiet and let me finish hey George
Soros you're a real competitor I respect
you I'm worth more money than you and I
have more influence in you and have you
know Pierce Morgan from a different
country saying well the uh I'm not gonna
do an English accent because that would
be racist uh I'm funny by the way uh
fine
to you the show is uncensored yet here's
your chance to clarify what you meant by
death gone three on Jewish people
foreign
well thank you for allowing me to say
what I meant due to the fact that I was
blocked by Jewish people after I said
that so I wasn't actually allowed to say
what I was about to say well you were
removed from whatever you removed from
social media I I
always said you're not allowing me to
talk Chris okay Chris
Oh I thought it was the same person
he's American I'm British
on reflection sometimes you look back
and wish you hadn't said things is that
accurate
nah not really
because
the things I say are on behalf of God
like it's not always Godly because I'm a
man but God is definitely using me just
to clarify one thing though you are
actually divorced are you because my
understanding was that you weren't
actually divorced yet
you know I asked God the same question
some mornings
a divorce God that deaf and questioned
the means he had I was put on camera I'm
not saying you don't traumatized I'm not
feeling la la la la I mean so let me
finish okay I'm not finished talking so
we can't I cannot I see because you
distract my thoughts and then you try to
make me look like a crazy person and you
feel you have the right to cut me off
and I've proven you you guys don't want
it with me this is like Terminator 20.
you've never seen this before first of
all I can't what is the beginning read
the whole tweet
I'm sure you have it in front of it
somebody in your office has it get him a
coffee and a yay tweet
[Music]
would you like one day to get back with
Kim do you think do you feel like you've
gone through a very tumultuous period
but that actually the love Underneath It
All between two people remains and would
you like to get back together
those thirst traps still be fire
because people call me [ __ ] they
treat me like I'm [ __ ] uh and so I
embrace it it's like you call somebody
so much they say I'm
you call somebody a [ __ ] so much they
say I'm a [ __ ] you call somebody a
[ __ ] somebody should say I'm
[ __ ] like I was exhausted and I
embraced the idea
of having a serious mental health uh
issue but Noah I mean not Noah Noah also
but Moses was basically on speed when he
was doing what he did by the way out of
Interest yeah how much sleep do you get
a night
I'm not here to talk about how much
sleep I get I don't literally just been
talking about how much sleep do how much
sleep do you get in there I had about
five and a half hours last night
actually not very much
um but but you're the one that's raised
this issue and I probably had the same
I'm not going to question your talent
your talent to me is completely
unquestionable right when you question
that question about the femur to the
dinosaur no I'm going to ask you for
this situation I'm just going to ask you
this what no you're not you're gonna
you're gonna know I didn't finish my
question well hang on you can't tell me
answer my question you can't tell me
what questions to ask you you accepted
that I'm the interview answer my
question no I said answer my question no
I'm interviewing you too well you can't
interview me it's my interview
your Bono I'm interviewing you too see
that's the way we wrap it let me just
you're gonna say that no no let me just
let me just put this so no no no no no
no you're trying to you no no no no no
no no
I'm gonna you're interrupting me now let
me go to the the next fiori which has
been around you in the last couple of
weeks which is your attack is that is
that is that is that is that is that is
that British for a theory is that
British for Theory
what's Theory bro is that British foot
Theory you actually have quite a good
British accent
that's quite good I mean as I'm like top
five writers in human exist in human
history so I really get into the way the
Power of Words and I feel very akin to
Capote Freud
um Nikolai Tesla uh Da Vinci Matisse
more Matisse than Picasso more African
cubism than Matisse uh so I just do that
I thought that's kind of for the
Liberals and that's the funny thing that
you know you're going to be bragging
you're going to be bragging at dinner
tonight like yo I talked to yay no one
could do it no one could do it I did it
interview adjourned love you
foreign
okay that's the end of the interview